hi everyone and welcome to the barely
coding youtube channel
i am your host daniel bark and in this
video we're going to take a look at
assembly script and what is that
that is a language that tries to
resemble the syntax of typescript
with of course a few limitations because
what it compiles to
is webassembly so i think this could be
the go-to language for javascript and
typescript developers that want to write
webassembly we're going to implement a
few functions
then we're going to verify these
functions by writing some tests
after that we're going to run a
benchmark so we're going to implement
the same functions in javascript
and then compare the performance to see
where we do
gain some performance by using
webassembly i'm going to see if we can
identify some pitfalls because there is
a price to pay when you talk between the
javascript and the web assembly modules
so let's jump into the code
[Music]
okay so let's see what that init got us
we got a new dependency which is
the loader that can be used to import
webassembly modules
we have some scripts so as build
untouched
that will build the debug version
we have as build optimized that will
build an optimized release version of
our code
and if we run just npm run as build it
will run both of them
we also have some tests and those are
located in
tests index.js so it's using the node
library assert which is a built-in
library node
imports the module here it tries the add
function
so that tells me that there should be
an add function in this file now so
here's the add function so this is
pre-compilation
so it says this is the entry file of the
web assembly module
so we have just the add function here we
have some
config for typescript tells typescript
that this
is assemblyscript not regular typescript
so
if we look now in the index.js we see
that it
it's using loader which is the
assemblyscript loader the path
is build optimized so this file will use
the
the release files for now and then it
does a re-export
it takes the was the module exports and
places them on this files exports
which means that we can import
the webassembly modules from this
file so that's what this test file is
doing it's going up level
importing in that folder which would
lead to this file so here it's asserting
it's testing the webassembly add
one plus two should be three so now i
should be able to do
npm run tests
and it says okay and i think that was
correct
yeah it said okay we can also do a
console
log my
my module dot add
two and two let's see if we get four
outputs as well yeah and we do okay
cool so we have the build step
working and we have the tests working so
now let's add another function here
now we're going to create a factorial
function
taking a number again
we will return a number this will be a
recursive function so we will return
if i equals zero
then we return one else we return
i times we'll call
ourselves with i minus one so
if three comes in here then
i is not zero so then we will go
to here with three times factorial of
two
second time we will take two times
factorial of one
so what this will end up being will be
three times two times one and so on
if i call this function with three i
should get back a six
so now we made some changes so now let's
do npm run as build again
seem to have gone okay
so now we can try
factorial we'll call it with
three and we should expect that to be
six we can do it like this and say
add is okay
factorial is okay
we can do a console log
factorial
my module dot factorial and three
let's run the test
so that was okay factorial was returning
six
and ok
great so now we have two functions
so now let's start looking at how to
benchmark this
so we'll do npm install benchmark
and let's create a new file
call it benchmark.js
bench mark equals
required
and we need to import our western
modules
so we'll do require this folder that
will lead us to the
index.js
let's set up a suit here run
suit small path in the suit
this means the test suit we can
console that we started running
suit of name and let's say suit
on
the cycle event we'll set up a callback
we get in an event here
we'll just console load
the event.target chain on
another one here
complete i'm not sure we can have these
as
arrow functions because i'm going to use
this
to access the suit this dot filter
for fastest
map name one
let's start out with our
add test and
and test
so we'll do function and js so this will
be the
js version of add
a plus b
and the assembly script version
is lassen.add
so let's set up a new test test equals
benchmark dot suit
call it just add and now
we run this test so we do test and
we'll start with the assembly
script
so we'll just add 10
to 20 and then another one
for
javascript so now we can do
run suit we'll pass
in our test and all we need to do down
here
is call add test let's add
the benchmark as a script in here
bench mark
let's try it out benchmark
running ad okay i'm missing something
here
okay i think it's this
now it should work better
and let's go again now we should see
some results
okay now it seems to be running so we'll
run
many times through each of these
tested ads okay
so now we got the result so the assembly
script was called 88
times and the javascript 84 times
and then averaged operations per second
we see that javascript was a lot faster
it was able to execute a lot of more
operations per second so we can see when
this really
simple function runs then the cost of
switching to assembly script
is a lot higher than what you gain
from the actual speed okay but the
factorial function
in that one we can make the funker
function run a lot
longer so i think that one should be
quite interesting
so let's copy this ad test
so we'll call this factorial
factorial
factorial and this one we need to
implement
factorial
call it js js so we have just one
in parameter so we do the same we do
return
i
i return i
equals zero if one equals zero
then we just return one otherwise we
return
i times factorial js
with i minus one
okay and let's fix these parameters here
we can run it let's run it with 20
and with this one i want to split it up
in two tests
so i'll call it factorial small
small small
small
i'll do the same for large let's do 20
here and for the small one we'll just do
three
test large 20
and here we also do test large
okay and then we just call
factorial test
we can
skip add test for now let's run another
benchmark
okay start with the small one assembly
script is done
okay javascript came out ahead just a
bit
so it's 27 million ups per sec
versus 35 million ups per sec
so javascript won that one if we look at
the larger factorial
we can see that assembly script was it
was an
even racing the small one but for the
large one
assembly script was quite a lot of quite
a lot faster
so assembly script won this factorial
one when we used
a factorial of 20 so that's pretty cool
so there we could actually make
some gain but what i also want to try is
what happens if you pass a large payload
into assembly script
okay let's create a new function we'll
call this one
square array it takes
an array and this is an int 32
array and it returns an int
32 array so an array of the same
size will go in and then come out but
squared
so the length
is array.length we'll allocate an array
for the result
mu int 32 array of
length length and now let's start
looping
so we'll do four let i equals
zero i smaller than length
i undo plus plus i
so we'll take e from array
i result i
is equal to e times
e and then we return
result we're now finished with the
square array
now we need to add some stuff here
because we're passing an array
between webassembly and javascript
so we're going to export some type ids
here
and you will see why in just a bit but
let's do in
32 array underscore id this is what we
call the variable
and we'll use a function called idle
and then int 32
array
like this so this will give us the id of
that type
okay so now we have exported that type
so now let's go to
where we import the webassembly module
so here we're actually going to create
some glue code
for this function so we're going to
create
square array here as well where we just
take in the webassembly version of
square array
and we glue it together and we export
this version of square array
that is calling the webassembly square
array version
so here we get passed in the array this
is the array that comes from our
javascript file
destruct the square array
from the wasm
module dot exports
we can call it wasm
square array we also need some more
things
we need our type int
32 array
id is what we called it now we could do
this const
result equals square
awesome square array
so you might think that
we could just do this
so you might think that this would work
but it won't
we have to first instantiate an
array that is of the correct type so
we'll
call this typed array so we're going to
create a typed array with the
correct type so we will import the
function
new array from here and we'll also
import the function get in
32 array
so we can use this one to instantiate
the array
and here is where we give it give it the
type id so
int 32 array id and then the array
that comes from javascript land this
function takes the javascript array
and the type id returns a typed array we
can then
pass this typed array
into the wasn't square array
but in order for this one to come back
as a javascript array again we need to
wrap this in the get
in 32 array
like this this is the most complicated
part of it but
here is where we get the array to match
the
wasm type and here is where we take the
wasm type
and make it to match javascript land
again
now we need to add this
square array to our exports here cool
uh let's compile our files npm run as
build
okay let's write
a test for this one square
array okay square array
and this one we can do one two
three four we expect that
to be one 4
9 16.
and then the strict equals should be
deep strict equal
d strict equal npm run test let's see if
we need to do any more thing with the
types
and we get an error here let's see if we
need to do this
new int 32
array now when i'm running it it says
operation requires compiling with
export runtime so let's add that to our
as config
to the release export
export runtime
true
okay let's compile it again
okay npm run test okay
it worked now so let's see if we
actually needed this
type on this array or if it's happy with
just this for the test to pass
okay it's not happening that
let's leave it like that then
cool test pass we can square our array
using webassembly now let's do the
benchmark
so let's copy the factorial one we're
taking an array
js so let's do the same
let's copy this one
this one is square array
square grade
test small is
square a
small
square array assembly script
and square array javascript
so here we'll do one two three because
this is a small one
one two three okay let's copy the small
test
large
large
okay now we only need to make this
longer
okay remove the factorial test and
call square array
test npm round bench
mark
okay so for the small one javascript was
a lot faster
so as we can see that the assembly
script
had about the same performance in both
where javascript lost a bit of
performance
when the square array was large so let's
create a really large array
so let's do new in
32 array
of length hundred
let's fill it with once
and then this map val index
val plus i times
0.01
and now let's try it with this large
array instead
so now the test large will be of length
hundred
okay now it was
the difference was a lot smaller let's
see if we can make this
a thousand
okay so we have some interesting results
here the interesting thing here
is that what we learned from the
factorial one
is that if assemblyscript
would have been able to produce this
array or have this
array already in memory it would crush
javascript in the performance like we
see
in the factorial test so in this example
we can see that there are lots of losses
when we're passing this
a large array between javascript and
webassembly so i'm going to quickly
type together the same test
but this array is generated on the
assembly script side so we don't have to
pass the big payload
okay so now i created it in this version
we just pass in the length of the array
that we want
so we don't have to pass a large payload
between
the javascript world and the webassembly
world
so now let's see what performance we get
let's call square array
gen test
oops let's not run all of them
so here we are doing it with
200 elements and in the small test we're
doing it with 20 elements
so as you can see in the large test
assembly script was over two times
faster
and now we're running the small test in
the small test
it was still faster but not by as much
so as what we can conclude from this is
that the size of the payload that we
pass
between javascript and webassembly
matters a lot
so what we can learn from this is that
the size of the payload that is being
passed between javascript and
webassembly matters a lot
but if we can have the data already on
the webassembly side
and there are at least a few iterations
that are going to be run
then webassembly will quickly regain the
lost time
of switching the contexts this was super
interesting
the code will be available on github and
you can check it out
and try it yourself thank you so much
for watching if you like the content
then subscribe to the channel
share it with a friend thumbs up the
video and i hope to see you in the next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
video
[Music]
you